The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open CourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So let's get started today.
Again, the topic is fare policy,
structure, and technology.
So we'll cover policy
objectives, the issues
that agencies face,
fare structure,
demand response to fare
changes and fare technology.
So what are the
objectives of fare policy?
There are multiple objectives,
and they don't necessarily
support each other.
In fact, they often
go against each other.
So the number one objective
is to fund operations.
That's the reason there's
a user fee for service.
And I say here at
least partially
because for the most part,
the revenues obtained
by fare collection do not cover
the full operational costs,
let alone capital costs.
So here we have some examples
of fare recovery ratios
based on the 2014
National Transit Database.
Now, you might
remember that we talked
about the National
Transit Database
earlier in this course.
And here is a breakdown.
I looked at all
heavy rail and I saw
a range of between 0.14 0.78.
So between 14% and 78%
of operational expenses
are covered by fare revenue.
The highest one here
is in California.
For light rail a little lower
and for bus all over the place.
Here we have the averages.
These tend to be higher
for rail and lower for bus.
So why is that?
Why would that be the case?
AUDIENCE: On an
operational level,
one rail driver is carrying
a lot more passengers
than one bus driver.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Although you can
fill up a bus, right?
AUDIENCE: You can fill up a
bus [INAUDIBLE] train carrying
500 passengers.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Yeah.
So to sort of go
back to my rebuttal,
there are some buzzers here with
fare recovery ratios over one.
So it's possible to have a bus
service that returns profit
even.
So why is it that
system-wide, bus services
tend to have lower
fare recovery ratios?
Because you have a good point,
the productivity of rail
can be higher.
Of course, if rail
is underutilized,
then you still have that issue.
Any other ideas?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Buses [INAUDIBLE]
who can have the most service
and cover the most
low ridership routes?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
So there's an agency
and you system-wide
have to cover your territory.
That will include buses that
are not very heavily utilized.
Also, you're
providing service late
at night and all those things.
So there are many cases of buses
not being very well utilized,
and that brings down
the fare recovery ratio.
I did not include here
demand responsive.
Demand responsive is
usually around 1% to 2%.
So I'm talking about
what here in Boston
is called the ride for
disabled passengers.
And it can cost
around $20 per ride,
and people pay a lot less.
So I think $20 is low.
I think it's higher.
Sorry.
I don't remember the number,
but it's closer to $30 or $40,
I think.
So the fare recovery ratio
for demand responsive transit
is much lower.
OK.
So other goals.
Keep transit affordable
and promote social equity.
So here we have the
first conflicts, right?
The first objective would mean
that you want to raise fares,
and if you raise fares then
you get more fare revenue.
But there's another
objective, which
is to keep transit affordable
and for social equity,
and that would indicate that
you want to keep fares low.
Right?
So also, supporting growth
for demand of transit
also keeps fares low.
Make the fare structure
easy to communicate.
We'll talk about different
fare structures and market
segmentation later
in this lecture.
But the point is that when
you do market segmentation,
you can get more revenue
out of your fare system.
When you want to
keep things simple,
then you're probably going to
suggest going for a flat fare
structure, where people that
have much higher willingness
to pay are still
paying low fares.
So that objective
of keeping the fare
structure easy to
communicate and simple
will reduce fare earnings.
And finally, to reduce
fare system costs.
So there are costs
to fare collection
and to the fare
system as a whole.
Fare collection is one of them.
So obviously, the capital cost
of installing the fare boxes
and maintaining the
whole AFC system.
There is a cost for people
who are maintaining those fare
boxes and vaulting cash
out of the fare boxes
and counting the cash and
keeping it in a safe place.
And there's customer service.
So customer service involves
more than the fare system.
But some aspects
of customer service
involve my CharlieCard doesn't
work, can I get a new one?
Or I already paid
for that ride and you
need to give me a refund.
So these kinds of
inquiries or complaints
are coming from the fare system.
OK?
Questions about
these objectives?
No.
OK.
So how does fare policy
intersect with other areas?
It intersects with many areas,
and that makes fare policy
and fare structure a very
powerful sort of lever or knob
for a transit agency.
So obviously, finance.
We're talking about funding
operational expenses
from the revenues derived
from the fare system.
And then there's operations.
So if you have a fare policy
that makes people board faster
because, for example,
it's proof of payments
so there's no
validation required
or you have fare technology
that a smart card is
much faster than
paying cash, then
that means that you'll have
faster boarding, shorter dwell
times, shorter cycle
times, higher reliability.
So you might affect operations
through fare technology.
Some fare structures
require fare inspection.
So proof of payment is
one that people board
without interacting
with any fare system,
so then an inspector
has to come in
and either for all
passengers or more likely
for a subset of passengers, a
sample of passengers, request
proof of having paid the fare.
And of course, that
involves some cost.
There's maintenance
of equipment.
If equipment breaks
down, the bus
needs to be taken out
of service, et cetera.
Public support.
So politicians may
promise not raising fares.
That's a popular
campaign promise.
And then of course, that
puts a lot of pressure
on the agency to
do more with less.
And we'll talk more
about that when
we discuss transit finance.
There's difficulty gathering
support to raise fares.
Usually, we'll
improve service first
and then that justifies
raising fares.
Right?
I don't want my service
to get more expensive
if it's not very good service.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
And essentially, if you
have lower service quality,
then fewer people end up
taking it or liking it,
and those people
are not going to be
the ones rallying for a
transit sort of fare hike.
Then there's also labor's
push for higher wages.
So that's another sort
of political pressure
on the agency that
increases operational costs
and therefore, may require
an increase in fares.
But both a labor
dispute and a dispute
with the passengers
on the fare hike
are the result of unpleasant
negotiations or interactions
in public.
Administration, so fare
technology and fare policy
and equity analysis.
If you're considering any
change to technology or policy
or structure, you have to
analyze the economic aspects
of it and you have to
prove that you're not
discriminating against any one
group, even unintentionally.
So disproportionately affecting
a disadvantaged community,
either by race or income, that's
called Title VI in the US.
Then there's another
big policy issue
is revenue sharing
across jurisdictions.
Not so much an issue on the east
coast of the US, but certainly
if you go to the West Coast, you
have in the San Francisco Bay
Area dozens of operators.
Some of them share
the same fare system.
So how much does
each operator pay
for routes that serve
multiple jurisdictions?
That's one question.
The other question might be,
if we are separate operators
and we each have a route
so we take care of that,
we still are collecting
fares with a joint system.
Do we trust each other?
And often, actually, the
barriers to integration
are more about trust and
less about technology.
Marketing is another
sort of issue
the agency has to deal with.
How much do they market
and what is the message?
And customer service,
which we already mentioned.
It's interesting
to note that fares
are one of the first
things that a person
has to sort of understand
about a transit system
to be able to take them.
So if you're a tourist
and you go to a new city
that you've never been to
before you arrive at the airport
and you want to take the bus
or the train from the airport,
the first thing
you have to do is
buy a ticket, right, and
figure out the fare structure
and where are the
maps and et cetera.
So this is sort of one
of the first issues,
the first impression that a
passenger has about the fare
system, about the
transit agency, something
related to the fare system.
OK.
What issues do agencies
face regarding these topics?
One is fare recovery ratios.
So we looked at ranges.
Typically, fare recovery
ratio system-wide across modes
is about 1/3.
It varies a lot, as we saw.
It's rare to make
a profit system.
So one of the
issues is how much--
well, the first question is, how
much of a fare recovery ratio
do we need or do we set a goal
to cover operational expenses?
And is it sort of a
strong requirement,
as it is in some agencies?
Some agencies have laws that
say the fare recovery ratio must
be at least this much.
So if expenses go up,
automatic fare hike.
Others, it's more of a guideline
or maybe there is no policy.
So that that's one
of the key issues.
The second one is how
often to raise fares.
I think most agencies
are reactive.
So a reactive
approach is one where
you avoid the headache
of a fare hike
and all the sort of public
engagement that goes with it
and you only do that
when you have to so
you are in a financial
situation where you absolutely
need to raise fare revenues
to continue operating.
So that happens less
than once every year
and it's a big effort.
Some agencies take the
approach of an annual fare
hike with inflation.
So it's kind of
predictable, it happens
every year at the same date.
It tends to make each
one easier than one
done ad hoc because
it's more expectable
and there's less public outrage.
So gathering and maintaining
political support,
we talked a little
bit about that.
Of course, that is an issue that
will play out and sort of it
will affect how other issues
are faced and dealt with.
One other issue is do
we raise base fares
or do we change the relative
cost of passes and discounted
fare products?
So if a base fare
is $2, you might
have 50% subsidy
for seniors and you
might have some other discounts
for students or other groups.
You might also have passes
like a weekly pass, which
if you take some number
of trips you break even
and after that, you ride free.
So you might actually leave
the base fare the same
and change the percentages
of subsidy or discounts
or the break even
point of a pass.
And that can affect
fare revenues,
it can affect ridership, and
it can affect people's choice
of fare product.
So you might bump people towards
letting go of fare passes
and opting to do pay as you
go more often or the other way
around.
And that has implications
on how people
think about the transit system,
how much it costs for them.
For a pass holder, of course,
once they've paid for it,
it's kind of a
non-salient expense.
So you don't think
about it every time
you're tapping as much as having
value deducted from the card
every time.
So those people might
ride opportunistically
because they've
already paid for it
and they might do shorter
trips, discretionary trips
more so than someone
who is paying
every fare independently.
And another big
issue is investing
in new fare technology.
That's a headache,
a big headache.
You can imagine changing the
way the old technology, all
the analytics and administration
depends on uncertain system.
And bringing in a new system
that nobody understands yet
might work or not.
So all the maintenance
needs to be figured out.
And you have to communicate with
the public about what impact
that has on them, and
that could involve changes
in the fare structure,
not just the technology.
So sometimes technology enables
new fare structures or new fare
policies.
And that can be
one of the reasons
for bringing new technology.
Questions on the issues?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I wonder if the
rising fare issue
is less common in
privately operated system
than in public operated systems.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Can you give me an example?
I'm not sure I
follow the question.
AUDIENCE: In systems where
bus and rail are exceptions
to the private sector.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
Sometimes the public
sector is the one--
so if you look at
the case of London,
for example, even though
buses are operated
by private companies in
some way it's a contract
so the fare policy
is still set by TFL,
which is the government.
That's I think usually
the case if you
have a push for a unified
single brand of the system.
Maybe in other countries--
I'm thinking more of
Latin America, Africa--
there are sort of
independent people
running their own systems.
And those are usually
cash-based so there's
no integration whatsoever.
Maybe you have a
different example.
AUDIENCE: But No.
Still [INAUDIBLE] just
[INAUDIBLE] the government.
So I wonder if the type
of contracts [INAUDIBLE]
engage with the private
[INAUDIBLE] concessions.
I mean, there is a difference.
There is a myriad of
types of [INAUDIBLE]..
I wonder if that allows you more
flexibility to sort of delay
because you're under a contract
with a specific [INAUDIBLE]
negotiation [INAUDIBLE].
So I wonder if that give you
leverage to delay increasing
fares, as opposed to--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I'm not sure.
Frankly, I'm not sure.
Sort of the issues related
to concessions in that case
depend a lot on the
contract structure.
So some concessions derive
revenue from the fare.
I think that's not the
best way of doing it.
But if that's how the
contract is structured,
essentially, you say,
I want you to operate.
You keep the fares.
Then of course, any fare
question will affect revenues
and it will affect
ridership too.
So the private operator will be
interested in any kind of fare
policy change if that
increases their revenues
and will be disinterested in
any fare policy change that
decreases their revenues, or
increases the risk of revenue
anyway.
So that is probably
a poisonous topic
during the length of
a contract and you
might have to then do
it between contracts.
Here I'm speculating,
but I imagine
this is a case where you
pay to run by distance
or you might have some
performance standards as well,
but it's not fare so much.
So the government
keeps the fares
and then pays the operators
the contracted amount.
Then that disconnects the
operator's performance
from fare revenue and it allows
the government or the planning
agency to change the fare
structure, change fare
technology in the
middle of a contract.
And so in the former case, I
imagine it's quite complicated.
Because usually, the contracts
are not awarded on cycle, i.e.,
at a certain moment in time
you might have a contract that
expires next month; another
one that expires in a year;
another one that
expires in five years.
So to implement a
system-wide change,
it would be very
difficult if the contracts
depend on the fare revenues.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So a
couple of questions.
One, it seems like one of
the biggest choices you make
is whether to have
[INAUDIBLE] whether to have
a flat or a zoned fare.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
And we're going to talk
about market segmentation.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then about raising fares,
I see that the MTA in New York
battles to raise
fares, so I think
flow is really hard for them,
whereas when I lived London,
literally every single year on
January 1st, the fare changed.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
So that goes back
this sort of annually
with inflation and strategy
where you do it every year
and it just happens
on January 1st.
AUDIENCE: People get a big
grumpy, but [INAUDIBLE]
about it.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
Right.
And there are many
other examples
of that kind of approach.
I think it's more
effective, frankly.
Expenses go up every
year, so why not?
Communicate what the
strategy is, make it fair--
no pun intended-- and do it.
AUDIENCE: I read once that
King County Transit in Seattle
discounts fares
for people living
below the poverty line or
some threshold based on that.
[INAUDIBLE] Is
that pretty common?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
So we'll talk-- in
market segmentation,
one of the things
you might segment by
is socioeconomic status.
Yeah.
And there's different
ways of doing that.
So we can talk more about
that when we get there.
AUDIENCE: I have
another question.
I also have heard it
argued that with the switch
to all electronic
tolling that it
increases [INAUDIBLE] obscures
how much you actually pay.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
This is a saliency issue.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] switch
from cash-base fare system to--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Especially if you go to
passes or a capping scheme,
which we'll discuss.
So yeah.
The more obscure, you
make the fare system,
the less of an impact it
will have on demand response.
And that is true in other areas.
If you look at it from a
macroeconomic perspective,
that's true in business.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't that
mean the more obscure you
make it, the less--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Well,
if people don't understand
pricing, it may be you might
get a sort of lower reaction
to changes in pricing.
You make less of
a fuss about it.
OK.
Fare structure, so
market segmentation.
That's a good segue
with these questions.
So one possible way of
having a fare structure
is to have a flat
fare structure.
That's the simplest one.
It costs some amount to
ride, no matter what.
No matter where from,
what time of day,
what mode, that's the price.
So again, that's the simplest.
I think most
agencies, if you look
at the profile of all
agencies, including small ones,
have that fare structure.
Bigger agencies tend to have
some market segmentation
because they are bigger and they
serve a wider range of people,
they serve a wider
geographic area,
and they have some
congestion problems.
So how can we
differentiate fare,
how can we segment the market?
One is spatially.
So you could have a flat
geographic structure
where no matter where you
ride from, it costs the same.
You could have zones.
So here in Boston, we have no
zones outside of commuter rail.
We have no zones.
When you go to London, there's
zones one through nine,
but most of the greater London
is in the first three, about.
So it costs more to cross zones
than to ride within a zone.
And you can buy passes that are
zone 1, zone 1-2, et cetera.
So that's one way of doing it.
If you take that to the extreme
and imagine many, many zones,
you could end up with something
called distance-based pricing,
where each of the pair
has a different fare,
depending on how
long that ride was.
So you can do that if you
have a tap-in, tap-out system,
you can do that with proof
of payment in some cases.
It's more common in Europe.
And regarding zones,
a lot of agencies
used to have more
zones and are going
for reducing zones and
simplifying the system.
It's an interesting,
curious trend
because they've been doing
this at the same time
that they've been investing
in new fare technology that
enables more complex
fare structures.
But it's a choice of
communicating to the public
and keeping it simple,
easier to understand.
AUDIENCE: And do a couple
of years' long advertising
campaign to get
people to figure out
how to cap for the
overground system, which
is part of the TFL.
Because you could essentially
go around the entire city just
in zone 2.
But if you don't tap
in in the right way
when you transfer
trains or something,
it will think you went
into the city and out.
It's a lot cheaper to go
regularly than it is to go--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
Because you stay in one zone.
AUDIENCE: It was so confusing.
They had people on the
platforms explaining it.
AUDIENCE: Is DC Metro an
example of distance-based?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
In some ways, yes.
They have many sort of
things that influence price.
So I don't know if you've had
the experience of going to CRB
and trying to figure out
how much money to put
on your smart trip card because
it varies by time of day
or how long you are
going to travel.
And you don't necessarily
know that ahead of time,
so you end up loading--
it works in their favor.
I just load up $20
or $40 depending on--
I don't really figure out how
much my rides will cost and put
in just that amount.
Eventually, maybe I lose my
card and they keep the revenue.
OK.
Another-- oh, Eli.
AUDIENCE: So you said
that you really need
a tap-in, tap-out system
for distance-based,
but for zonal [INAUDIBLE],,
how do you run that?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It could
be proof of payment as well,
not just check-in, though.
So in Europe, you
have some symptoms,
especially it happens
more intercity.
So you buy a ticket between
this station and that station
and you have a paper ticket.
And you when you board you
validate it so essentially,
it gets canceled
with a timestamp.
And if a fare inspector
comes, you better have one.
Otherwise, you'll
be heavily fined.
So that's one way of doing it.
Any other questions?
OK.
Temporal segmentation, so
that's pretty straightforward.
You've got a flat
system where there
is no change in fares
across time of day
and another one where
you have a peak surcharge
or an off-peak discount.
Same thing, two ways
of marketing it.
Most agencies prefer to
offer a discount on off-peak
than to charge more
during the peak,
but it's all psychological.
So why would an agency
be interested in doing
this and what are the impacts?
Henry.
AUDIENCE: It would influence
people to maybe think more
about taking the trips during
off-peak so that there are
alternatives that they--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
So nudging people who can
do off-peak to do off-peak
rather than during the peak.
What else?
Any other ideas?
AUDIENCE: Just encourage
more off-peak ridership
in general, like people
should probably do this.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
So more discretionary trips.
So encourage more
off-peak ridership.
OK.
And why does it make
sense to charge more
during the peak than
off-peak, regardless
of how you market it?
AUDIENCE: Some people
are [INAUDIBLE] flexible
in their schedules and
[INAUDIBLE] capture that.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Exactly.
So willingness to
pay is higher, either
because they are
actually willing
or because they are
captured on time like they
have to arrive at some
time to work so they
don't have many options.
And that means that
they're much less flexible
and that their response will be
much lower to a price change.
OK.
By service, that's
pretty simple too.
You could charge the
same for bus and rail
or you could say rail is
a better service so it's
going to be more expensive.
The MBTA has this option.
Regular bus versus express
bus, another way in which
the MBTA segments the market.
So the idea is if it's a
nicer service, you pay more.
By socioeconomic status.
So students might get
a discount, seniors,
disabled might get a discount.
We have some rules
here where seniors
have to be offered
half the base fare,
so that's one example of that.
Some of it can be mandated
by the government.
And then there's
social programs.
So there's different
ways of doing that.
It could be as part
of your participation
in some social
program, it could also
be a needs-based subsidy
where you essentially
prove that you have financial
need and based on your need,
you give some amount of subsidy.
So a subsidy could be on or
off, you either have the subsidy
or you don't or it could
be depending on your need,
you have more subsidy
or less subsidy.
And usually, it's
the simpler one.
I don't actually know
of any example that
is done based on
your specific case,
but you could think
of doing it that way.
Because if somebody is
very, very poor then
they might need more
subsidy than somebody who
is just below the poverty line.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] is that
because those groups tend
to have less ability to
pay or what's the logic?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That is usually the logic.
So yeah.
Again, it's sort of
social equity goal.
So seniors and students
often can't drive, et cetera.
So it's the goal of the transit
agency or the transit provider
to increase mobility for
all groups of people,
the way in which that
goal is satisfied.
Henry.
AUDIENCE: How about
programs where
you can take out your income
pre-tax and [INAUDIBLE]??
Is that like a social program?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: No.
I do have that in
another lecture, yeah.
Because that is
done for people--
often, they are employee
who have a decent salary.
So that's an incentive.
And that incentive
exists for a car as well.
So that's a different strategy.
Another way of segmenting
is by willingness to prepay.
So in other words, are
you willing to buy a pass?
So if you can commit
to a whole month,
then you get some discount.
And this depends heavily on
what the break even point is.
Usually, passes-- it used
to be the case that passes
had heavy discounts.
So even without having a commute
two times a week for five days,
you would still get a discount.
Now it tends to require
sometimes between two
and three trips daily to
get that break even point.
Some people still decide to
go with that because it's more
convenient, it's less salient.
So it's another way of
discriminating or segmenting
the market.
Any questions on
market segmentation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
so speaking
of [INAUDIBLE],, the subsidies
given by government?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It depends.
So it could be
that the agency has
a mandate they have to do this.
That is often the model.
From an agency's
perspective it would
be much preferable to have the
subsidy come from someone else.
Because then that
would allow the agency
to focus on operating,
It would set fares
to what it needs to cover
operational expenses.
And then if it's a
social program, well,
why doesn't that social
program provide the subsidy?
If it's disabled, maybe there's
some other government entity
that can provide that subsidy.
For students, why
not the schools
or the Department of Education.
So that's an interesting
sort of policy debate
and we could talk about
it for a long time
because some people are
very much against it
and some people think
that's a good idea.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Also another thing
about the various groups that
are entitled to
subsidies is that you
have to have some mechanism
within your technology
that verifies that a
person is [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
To prevent fraud.
Yeah.
So smart cards are
helpful with that
because you can embed the
transit chip into a student
card, for example.
And that's what we
have here at MIT.
OK.
Fare elasticities.
So they can range from -1 to 0.
We know that demand of
transit is inelastic.
So it means that almost always,
virtually in every case,
if you raise fares, you
increase your revenue
and your ridership
decreases not by too much,
not by so much that your
fare revenues go down.
So here are some examples
of typical elasticities.
They usually are
closer to -0.3 or -0.4.
For rail, it's a little
less, so -0.2, -0.15.
For off-peak, it tends
to be twice as much
because more trips
are discretionary.
For work trips, it tends
to be much more inelastic,
as we discussed, so even
half of their base one.
And there's
something interesting
that is maybe not as
important anymore,
but I wanted to add it here.
There is a higher
demand for free transit
than there is for very,
very cheap transit.
Even if you have
to pay, say a cent,
to really get to the extreme,
the simplicity of not having
to deal with paying fares, not
having to interact with a fare
system, and from the marketing
point of view, it's free--
you can just take it
whenever, you don't
have to be ready to take it--
then that sort of
drives demand up.
So that's an
interesting finding.
A lot of agencies have
moved away from that
because these are
usually smaller agencies.
But of course, operational costs
increase and at some point,
you need to cover them somehow.
So these inelastic values
mean that raising fares
is an effective way of
increasing revenues.
Not so much to
increase the demand,
although sometimes some
aspects of fare policy
are changed to
increase the amount.
You know you're going to get
a small response to that.
From a microeconomics
perspective,
if you think about market
segmentation and running
transit like a
business, then you
would want to charge
more for longer trips;
trips in more convenient,
reliable, comfortable,
and frequent modes; peak
period trips; trips where
other modes are inconvenient
or costly, therefore this
is the best option and why
not charge more for it;
and trips subsidized
by third parties
because then you could
capture some of the increased
fare from an outside source.
All right.
So of course, not
everybody would
agree that this is what
agencies should do.
But if you are
thinking of running
an agency as a business, this
is exactly what you want.
If you have more willingness
to pay for whatever reason,
your fare is higher.
And that means that
fare revenues go up
and your fare recovery
ratio goes up.
And that means you can
operate more service
or you can operate more
reliably or you can
get nicer vehicles, et cetera.
All right.
So transfer pricing and policy.
Another issue,
some agencies don't
have any sort of
integration between rides
so every time you board a
vehicle, you pay a full fare
and there's no free transfer.
Some agencies have a
reduced price transfer
or a free transfer.
And free transfers can be
done in different ways.
One of the most
common ways is to have
a time-based free transfer.
So you tap and you
get, say, an hour
or two hours of free transit
starting from that point.
So if you transfer,
you'll presumably
be in this two-hour window
and the next time you tap,
it'll be a free transfer.
Here in the MBTA, the price
is higher for rail and bus.
So if you transfer from bus to
rail, you pay the difference.
If you transfer from rail
to bus, both are free.
Interestingly, with
this time-based rule,
you can often do something
very quickly and return
and these are actually
two different trips
and you would still
get a free return trip
and it's not a transfer.
So with more complex
fare rules, you
could say you should get free
transfers within this window,
but not if you are
on the same bus route
or if you are tapping into
the same station or things
like this.
You could think
of the rules used
for transfer insurance when we
discussed all the [INAUDIBLE]..
These are not fare transfers.
Those were sort of a
logical trip transfers
and you could apply those rules.
You could put them
into a fare engine
and not give free transfers
when it's not a transfer.
OK.
Pay-as-you-go,
passes, and capping.
OK.
One question before we--
Daniel.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there--
how do agencies
determine if it's unlimited free
transfers within the same trip
or [INAUDIBLE]?
Because [INAUDIBLE] bus,
rail, bus [INAUDIBLE]
have to [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
You usually
don't have to because they
set the window wide enough
so that you can get your
whole three-four trip done
in that two-hour window.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] trips and
I've been charged [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Oh.
In theory, I think you could
go to customer service and say,
this was a transfer.
Your policy is free transfers.
You need to refund me.
Yeah.
I don't know the
details of it, but I
imagine that's the case,
that you could argue
that you deserve a refund.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] paid
fare policy [INAUDIBLE]
reach your [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
I haven't, clearly.
It would probably be very
interesting, actually.
Any other questions
on transfers?
Transfers are more of
an issue when there are
multiple operators in a region.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about that.
If it's one operator, that's
sort of less controversial.
OK.
So pay-as-you-go
passes and capping.
So pay-as-you-go is the simplest
way of paying for trips.
You can do that with cash or
with tickets or smart cards
that have a balance.
So you load up some
value onto the card
and every time you interact
with a fare box or fare gate,
some amount of that balance
is deducted from the card.
That's pretty clear, hopefully.
Then there's passes.
So the idea of a pass is
that you sort of prepay
for three days, for a
week, sometimes for a day,
sometimes for a month.
And it's a fixed price so you
ride with zero marginal costs
after paying that fixed price.
If you ride frequently
enough, then you break even
and anything beyond
that is a free ride.
So it's interesting to note that
because passes are convenient,
some fare revenue is
derived from past sales
for people that
don't break even.
That could happen
for several reasons.
One of them might be
it's more convenient
and I'm not going to figure
out every month if I'm
going to be having the
pass or not the pass.
It could also be that some
people receive a subsidy
from somewhere and
what they spend
on the pass is lower
than the pass value.
And so for them, the real
break even point is lower
and you may not necessarily
be considering that when
you do this break even
point calculation.
So in some cases, going
back to transfers, agencies
that don't have
free transfers, you
can get them indirectly
through a pass.
Because they might
say, well, you
break even at 10 rides
per week so that's
your five weekdays times
two of going and returning.
And if you have no
free transfers policy
but your trip
requires one transfer,
then you're going to very
quickly reach that limit
and you're going to
ride free after that.
So in practice, that would
be a free transfer policy,
although not directly.
So passes increase
convenience, we know that.
The reduce saliency
so you're not
thinking about how much money
you're paying every time
because it's more convenient.
They can be subsidized by
employers, by universities,
by governments.
So here we talk about
the pre-tax benefit
that Henry brought up.
And then there are
social programs,
like access to jobs
programs, that give
passes subsidized or
sometimes even free
for people that are
economically disadvantaged.
Questions on passes?
I think we're all
familiar with passes.
OK.
So capping is less common,
it's a newer thing.
It's more common in Europe.
London has it, Germany has it
in many places, the Netherlands.
So the idea is that when
you have a complex fare
structure where the prices
are difficult to figure out,
then the agency says, don't
worry about calculating which
fare products you need
to buy; we'll do the math
and give you the best price.
So that's called
best price guarantee.
And the idea is that
instead of committing
to getting a pass
or not a pass, you
pay as you go but when you
reach a certain daily limit,
no more is charged
during that day.
So you can keep riding.
And that doesn't stop there.
So the card keeps
counting the trips
in one week, the
trips in one month.
And so you might
have multiple caps
and you might reach
different caps on one session
sort of with one card.
So essentially,
you end up getting
the equivalent of a pass if it
was worth it and not otherwise.
Obviously, that means
agencies lose some revenue
from people who didn't
make the right decision,
but it's one way of having a
complex fare structure that
heavily segments the
market and therefore does
obtain more fare revenues.
And it allows for simple
communication with people
by saying, don't worry about
it; we know it's complicated,
but we'll figure it out for you.
That's one argument.
In London, one of the reasons
capping was introduced
was with the movement to
contactless bank cards.
So essentially, you can pay
with your Visa or MasterCard.
You can have it on your phone,
Apple Pay or Android Pay,
you tap, it works.
So obviously, a
normal Visa might not
have the logic inside
the card's computer
to hold a pass or
anything like that
so the card becomes a token.
One way of dealing with
that is to say, it's capped.
We'll keep track of
your usage for the month
and when you reach
the monthly cap,
we'll stop charging you for it.
So it simplifies the move to or
towards contactless bank card
usage.
And we'll talk more about that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So since
London introduced this,
have they seen a drop in the
number of pass purchases?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
Well, they've seen
an increase in--
the penetration for
contactless bank card use
has been increasing steadily.
And if you go to London,
my last experience there
was on the train ride
between the airport
and the center of London, I
heard several people talking
about how convenient it was.
So people are
excited about this.
And it's great for
a city like London
that has a lot of
people that are
occasional users, a lot of
business travelers being
able to not have
to think about it
and just pay with a credit card.
It really helps.
And it has several
other benefits.
I'll discuss them more in detail
when we get to smart cards.
AUDIENCE: If you
say that it's capped
and you said that there's
a trend away from passes,
people are not buying passes.
But isn't that essentially
saying that actually,
no; people are buying
more passes than ever.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Well,
it's capping so it's not--
AUDIENCE: It's
capping, but it comes--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It's equivalent to a pass.
The math works out
so that it a pass,
but you're not selling
a monthly pass.
Yeah.
It's not a pass.
You're paying each ride.
AUDIENCE: --acts
like a [INAUDIBLE]..
It induces [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But I think if you go to
London every couple of months
and you can just
show up in London
and you don't have to fill up
an Oyster card or anything.
You can tap your card and use
it like you normally would.
If you ride too much in a
day, they cap it as well,
which is something they
don't do on a monthly pass.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
OK.
We'll discuss more on the
contactless bank cards.
This is a very interesting
trend that we're seeing.
So fare policy demand analysis,
we talked a little bit
about this on
ridership forecasting.
Just a little recap, the
traditional four-step modeling
process is not
usually appropriate.
And that's because A, it has
insufficient spatiotemporal
resolution and B, the planning
horizon for a fare hike
is kind of short- to
medium-term so you're not
thinking about land use changes
that will generate new trips.
So therefore, total amount
is, we can assume, fixed.
And what you want to play
with is the modal split
and the assignment
to specific trips.
The other thing is that these
four-step models usually
don't have all the details of
all the fare products in them.
And for an agency,
it's important to know
what people will do
about getting a pass
or paying as they go.
So usually, fare elasticity
analysis is simple;
in reality, a passenger is
considering multiple things
at the same time.
So which mode are
they going to take,
are they going to drive
their car or are they
going to take transit, are
they going to take bus or rail?
Fare products, are they
going to go for the pass
or are they going
to pay as they go?
And maybe there are
multiple passes, which one?
And then costs, not
just in absolute terms.
So usually,
elasticity only looks
at the percentage increase
in fares for this mode.
But what if car costs have
gone up by more than that.
So really, it's relative
to your alternatives
and each person might
have a different choice.
For some people, transit might
be the only mode of choice
[INAUDIBLE] the only
mode in the choice set
because they don't own a car.
For others, there may
be multiple options.
So the other aspect of it
is that exogenous factors
influence demand response and
they're not usually controlled
for.
So fuel prices, employment,
residential development,
tax policy,
sociodemographics, new modes--
the introduction of
TNCs like Uber and Lyft
and other companies have
potentially affected ridership,
we think they have.
And most of these
elasticity models
don't really sort
of control for that
to get the real fare
elasticity, and that
would be what you would want
to do, an accurate model.
OK.
Communication of fare policy.
So obviously, to the public
it needs to be communicated.
You can do that on
your website, you
can have near fare vending
machines there's usually you
know an explanation
of the prices,
you have a customer
service booths.
If there's going to be
a fare change, again
you post things on the website;
there's flyers and posters
everywhere; public
hearings, of course,
to sort of hear complaints
and defend the hike.
And I wanted to add one sort
of third emerging but very
important aspect that
we haven't figured out,
and it's via APIs or standard
feeds for trip planners.
So if you have an app or if you
use Google Maps to get transit
directions and you want it to
calculate what your fare will
be, unless the agency has
a simple fare structure,
that can't be done.
Even for agencies that have
a simple fare structure,
most of them don't
provide the two files
in GTFS that allow that
calculation to happen.
And for agencies like London
that have a capping scheme,
the GTFS specification
does not provide the means
by which to input the fare
rules that would accurately
calculate the person's fare.
Because you would
need to keep track
of how much they've taken
service over a week,
over a day, et cetera.
So that we haven't figured out.
Third party apps
like the transit app
would love to be able
to calculate fares
accurately and display them.
Because they can do
that for Uber and they
can do that for other modes,
so why not for transit as well?
And although they would
prefer to do that in-house,
one alternative to
that is to define
some sort of standard
API where it's
up to the agency to
calculate what that would be.
But you make an API
call and you say,
this is the hypothetical
trip that I'm planning.
Give me how much [INAUDIBLE]
and the agency would respond.
But for performance
reasons I think
the transit app
would prefer to be
able to do that
with their servers
so that there's
a quick response.
Partnerships, another
sort of emerging trend.
So employer partnerships
is one example.
I'll give you the
example of MIT, actually.
MIT has something
called AccessMyCommute.
Our lab was actually
involved in that.
So every MIT student
or employee badge
has a Charlie chip
embedded inside.
You can look at the back
and it says, Charlie inside.
And to employees, it's marketed
as an unlimited use pass.
So I can use my MIT
ID and ride the MBTA.
MIT gets billed on a
pay-as-you-go basis.
So the reason that
was the agreement
is that a lot of people
don't use transit enough
to justify the value of a pass.
So there was no
way that MIT would
agree to pay a pass
for every employee.
And it's in the interest
of MIT to foment,
to encourage ridership,
so to decrease saliency,
in this case to the
extreme by making it free.
So one way of doing that is to
say, market it as a free pass.
There is a mix of people that
had passes and people that
ride less often.
AUDIENCE: Could
MIT reach a point
where it might actually
want everyone to the pass
without the [INAUDIBLE]
employees knowing it
[INAUDIBLE]?
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: I don't
think so because many,
many employees-- yeah,
it's not close.
And some people ride
a lot more so MIT
in some ways for some
employees is paying more
because they're paying by ride.
But many people that
have a subsidized pass
because their break even
point is so much lower
don't really break even.
And so it works out to--
AUDIENCE: The next project
that project might do
is to find a way
to predict based
on the employee [INAUDIBLE]
this information
and they make a prediction
for what he's going to do.
And you might save MIT
a fair amount of money.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Well, one of the
reasons MIT decided
to do this is because
parking is very expensive,
real state is very
expensive-- very expensive.
And that's, of course,
not true everywhere.
It's not true in most places.
Most places have free
parking, plenty of land.
But in a place that has high
density, building new parking
is very expensive and you
could use that real state
for something else.
In fact, MIT has taken a
parking down near Sloan
and is making a
new building there.
So it costs less to
provide transit to people
and to encourage
people to take transit
than to build new parking
and maintain parking.
Here's another example.
So the Chicago
Transit Authority has
partnerships with other
transportation providers.
And they do that by providing--
there are some passes and
some fare products that
allow riding in PACE, which
is the original bus provider;
Metra, which is the
commuter rail provider;
and Divvy, which
is the bike share.
So you can buy things that--
there are some partnerships that
allow some integration here.
And there is a trend towards
mobility as a service.
So the idea of
mobility as a service
is that you make a monthly
payment for a bundle
of transportation options.
Here's an example.
You could have unlimited transit
pass five bike rides and five
TNC rides.
So you provide this bundle.
The person is purchasing
my transportation from home
to work and back on a
combination of both.
So if it's today it's
inconvenient to take transit,
that day I will use the
bike share or the TNC.
The word is out on whether
this will work or not.
Many agencies are
interested; most of them
don't want to talk about it.
And we'll see what
happens as time goes by.
AUDIENCE: Is the
reason that MIT is
hesitant to extend the transit
benefit to grad students
because grad students tend
not to be parkers so we
don't have that bargaining?
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: That is
sort of a reason for why they
shouldn't or wouldn't, but I'm
not sure that it is
the actual reason.
I think this was always
conceived as an employee
benefits program.
AUDIENCE: Aren't
we like employees?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Not quite.
So yeah.
So I don't really know
the actual reason.
Sometimes decisions
are made for--
you justify them in all sorts of
ways and then someone decides.
So many other factors play in.
OK.
Fare control.
Tap in, you know what that is.
You interact with a
fare box or fare gate
only when you're entering
the system or vehicle.
Tap in and tap out, you do
that when you enter and exit.
Usually, tap in and tap out
is for systems that have zones
and you tap out so
that we know if you've
traveled multiple zones
or not and therefore, we
know how much to charge you
because of the segmentation
by geography.
It also happens when there
are multiple agencies sharing
the revenue.
So intercity bus in some cities,
if a person takes a bus route
within a city, then that
revenue would go to that city.
If the person travels
across cities,
then the revenue would
be shared across cities.
So that's one way you
might want to do this.
I know that it does exist
in some places for bus
where you have to
tap in and tap out,
although it's much less
common for bus than for rail.
Henry.
AUDIENCE: If the tap system
introduces a day pass,
for example, where
[INAUDIBLE] go to multiple--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Then would
they just [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: I
don't know how they do it.
Funding formulas
are a huge debate.
And as an engineer, I would
propose to look at their OD
and figure out the most fair
way of allocating that revenue.
But how would they actually
do it is probably simpler.
Another thing about
tap in and tap out
is that you may require
internal vending machines.
It may increase
your capital costs.
Why is that?
Because you have multiple costs.
The price of your ride
depends on how far you ride
and if you cross zones or not.
So you might have
just enough balance
to enter, not enough to exit
if you cross multiple zones.
So you might have
to top up the card
before being allowed to exit.
That means you
need a fare vending
machine that a person
can use to top up
if they don't have a pass.
It means that you might
need a station attendant
to deal with somebody.
If the fare vending
machine is not working
or my bank card is not
working and is being rejected,
I need to get out
of the station.
I'm trapped.
So what do I do?
So it can increase
costs in that way.
You had a comment?
OK.
No.
Right.
So that's one potential issue.
Something that some agencies do
is allowing a negative balance.
So when we are
softening the blows
to allow when you tap
out to go below zero.
Next time you fill up the card,
you top up, if you put in $20
and you had a $1 deficit,
your balance is now $19.
You can't do that if cards
are [INAUDIBLE] because people
will then toss the
card and get a new one.
So you make people buy the.
The cards are maybe $10 and
a $5 balance or something.
So there's a disincentive
to tossing the card
and getting a new one.
And by the way, smart
cards cost money.
They're not that cheap.
Some agencies have paid $10
per card for their card.
Proof of payments, we
sort of discussed that.
You buy a ticket.
It might be OD, it
might be flat fare.
It doesn't matter, you buy
the ticket that you need.
And then when you board,
there's usually some validator
that prints a time stamp.
It can be electronic as well.
And what it requires
is fare inspection.
So at random, a fare inspector
will board the vehicle
and have a handheld device
requiring people to confirm.
If it's an electronic system,
then they'll tap on here
and I want to make sure that
you've actually validated.
If it's paper, then they
would look at the paper
and make sure that you've
canceled it or validated
that paper ticket.
And otherwise, big fine.
So the discouragement to fare
evasion is through fining
and through policing.
But the research shows
that there are still
higher fare evasion
rates on systems
that are proof of payment.
People opportunistically board
and they don't pay anything.
OK.
Fare technology.
So we've talked about
structure and policy,
let's talk about technology.
So this is how an AFC
system is usually set up.
You have a fare engine.
It's a server that has
all the fare rules in it
so it can calculate fares
based on a sequence of taps.
And it's connected
to different things.
So a fare vending
machine, that's
where you purchase your
card or your ticket.
So these are usually
fiberoptic connections
or hardline connections
and so they're fast.
It's a real-time validation.
As soon as you buy
a card and add value
to it from a fare
vending machine,
that balance is usually updated.
If the fare engine
has a balance in it,
it will be updated
in the fare engine.
That's not always the case.
There's many kinds of systems.
So customer service
booths are also connected,
fare gates are usually
connected as well.
So when you tap
into a fare gate,
there's a quick communication
with the fare engine saying,
is this card valid, yes or no?
Is there a balance?
If so, deduct balance.
This is how much balance
needs to be deducted.
And the fare gate opens.
Or maybe the fare engine
says, no, the card's not good.
Sound the alarm, don't open.
There are other
ways of doing it.
So the card itself might hold
the balance and the fare gate
might have the logic to
decide whether to open or not.
But there's a whole range
of ways in which this
can be configured.
Fare boxes and
validators are usually
on vehicles, although there
can be handheld validators.
Again, a validator is more
often used for proof of payment.
A fare box is used when
it's pay-as-you-go or pass,
so that's what we
have here in Boston.
There's two ways of doing this.
It used to be the case
that they were not
communicating in real
time with a fare engine.
So the card and the fare
box have a little chat
and decide how much
value to deduct.
Later, the bus reaches the
garage or it's being cleaned
and at the garage there's
a garage server that
wirelessly probes the
fare box and extracts
all the data from it.
And only then will
the fare engine
receive the information
about what transactions have
been done in that fare box.
So you might have, again,
a real time validation.
It can be a little
slow over the air.
So what happens, and this is
being done London, for example,
with contactless
bank cards, what
happens is that maybe the
first time the card is seen,
there is this dialogue
and validation.
After the card is
marked as trusted,
then it can just
validate immediately
and the actual deduction
can wait a little bit
and be sent in batches
to the fare engine.
There's a cash
vault. That's where
if your system accepts cash
when the bus or fare box reaches
the garage, that cash
vault is taken out
and the cash needs to be counted
and moved out of the fare box
and to a safe place.
Smart cards themselves
are computers.
They are small computers
with a battery and a clock
and some amount of
processing power.
So they have some
memory, so they
can hold some history
about your last trips.
They can hold how much balance
there is in some cases.
They are able to encrypt
and decrypt communication
so that it's harder
to break the security
and say add balance your card.
And I want to add although
this is not necessarily
part of the fare system,
data [INAUDIBLE]..
Increasingly, we are
doing a lot of analytics.
So usually, there's
some connection
between the live production
system and a data warehouse
where on a daily
or a weekly basis,
there's an extract of data
into a data warehouse.
And that allows analysts to run
heavy queries on a server that
is dedicated to analysis and not
on the live system [INAUDIBLE]
whether or not to open a
fare, if that makes sense.
OK.
Fare media.
Any questions about fare
technology and the framework
of how this is set up?
There are lots of
variants and I didn't
get into the details of
how any one system works.
OK.
So fare media.
Cash, we all know
what that is; tokens.
So I don't need to
go into how cash
is minted or anything, right?
So tokens are little coins
that you buy with money
and it's like a
ticket in some ways.
It has some value
and sometimes it's
possible to be able to have
to pay two tokens for a ride,
although usually it's just one.
They're being phased
out because they
can print paper tickets
with magnetic stripes
and there's more data to it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
So they still exist.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
They still exist.
Yeah.
This is a Boston token, by
the way, this one right here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: No.
I'm pretty sure this
is an old Boston token.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Yeah.
Maybe I'm wrong, but I
think that's the case.
OK.
Tickets.
So tickets are they're
printed on paper
and they have a magnetic stripe.
They don't have a
computer in them.
The magnetic stripe
holds information
that can be encrypted.
So it can be, but it's
not always encrypted.
It's a little easier for there
to be fraud with tickets.
So if there are
questions on tickets,
I'll talk more about them.
Smart cards I've talked about.
Mobile ticketing
is another option.
So that's a recent development.
You have an app, you pay
for a ticket for your ride
on the app.
And it's usually kind of
a proof of payment system
where a fare inspector comes
along and scans a QR code
on the app, proving that
you've purchased a valid fare
for that OD pair, for example.
This is being used here in
commuter rail in Boston.
And then the sort of newest
form is contactless bank cards.
So that's a wireless Visa,
MasterCard, credit charge card,
debit card and you
tap it on the--
there you go.
You can pass it if you want.
Can I see it?
So you tap it just
like you would
a Charlie card or an
Oyster card in London
and there's the dialogue
between the fare and the card.
Strong encryption.
As I said, the full
validation process
doesn't always happen,
especially in bus,
because you can trust the card.
There is a separate antenna.
Of course, the frequencies and
the protocols are different.
But there are good
standards for this
and London has moved to this.
CTA's system is based
on this technology,
even though they opted
to only use token cards.
So it's the same
technology, but it's
branded as their own thing.
And I don't know if they can--
now it does, right?
But at the beginning, it wasn't.
AUDIENCE: I met someone
who had a problem--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So with this, as you
have more and more cards
on your wallet that
are contactless,
you should get like
a copper-lined wallet
or something, to
like copper sleeves.
They exist to sort of prevent
two reads from the same card.
AUDIENCE: So if I have
a contactless bank card,
can I just walk up to one
of those systems and tap in?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
absolutely nothing?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Absolutely nothing.
You just get on the bus.
Yeah.
It used to be the
case in Chicago
that it was kind
of their own thing
and you were given a card.
It was the same thing
as a credit card,
but just as a token with no
balance or account on it.
And now they've enabled this.
So that's the new way.
AUDIENCE: But there
are other issues
about that because
there are issues of what
if the card is from a different
country and things like that?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Again, you do validation.
There are policies.
That's what these
card companies do.
They're good at it.
There is insurance for fraud.
So they-- yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's a big push
from Visa and MasterCard
to get [INAUDIBLE] contact
list because [INAUDIBLE] money
[INAUDIBLE].
So every way they can make
it easier to spend money
is better for them.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Eli, you have a comment?
AUDIENCE: And in Chicago,
it doesn't process transfers
or passes.
They're just charging
you a la carte, one trip.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So there's
they don't have
a capping scheme.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And it doesn't [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So if you want a pass,
that's not an option for
you is what you're saying.
AUDIENCE: You need to
actually [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
Yeah.
So that's an interesting
comment which no one heard.
I'm sure the comments on the
back are also interesting.
AUDIENCE: They're just
asking me about [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I'm generally interested.
Can you share with the class?
AUDIENCE: They were just
asking whether you actually
have to [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Oh.
OK.
AUDIENCE: You do have
to take it [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
As opposed to EMV, yeah.
AUDIENCE: But
[INAUDIBLE] Chicago
have it because I
thought it [INAUDIBLE]
penetration [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: But
I think they will increase.
And that I think could be driven
by agencies in big cities,
actually.
That's one example of that.
The US has been a little
late in adopting credit card
technology in general.
All right.
Smart cards.
So I've already talked
a little bit about them.
They enable more
complex fare structures,
they allow faster boarding
and higher gatebank throughput
because the validations are
much faster than a ticket.
A magnetic stripe ticket
needs to be fed in
and read multiple
times sometimes
and it takes more
time to do that.
Certainly, cash is slower.
So account registration is one
of the benefits of smart cards.
You don't have to do
this, but you often can.
So you open an account and that
gives you balance protection.
If your card is lost, you
can log into your account
and remove that card.
The balance could be
retained on the account
so you can get a new card
associated with that account
and you have your balance.
Autoload is another convenience.
You might have a rule that says,
if my balance drops below $5,
charge $20.
So if it's top up
or pay-as-you-go,
then this one feature.
Of course, it's much better for
us sort of researchers and data
nerds, better data for
analysis and planning,
longitudinal studies.
You can track a
token longitudinally
and understand more
about behavior.
It's embeddable in employee and
student budgets, as we've seen.
They are more
expensive than tickets.
Now there are some smart
tickets so you can print a card
with a chip circuit inside.
Those are a little cheaper.
One issue with smart cards is
that a lot of these systems
are proprietary.
And there are some standards,
but there are several
standards-- too many of them--
and they don't all
work everywhere
and so you can't
really use a card
from one system
on another system.
That's usually not the case.
There are some
exceptions to that.
There is a move towards open
source hardware specifications.
New York is a good
example of that.
They recently did
some procurements
where they asked all
the parts to be--
it was for an AVL
system in this case--
to be open source hardware
and communications technology.
That means they're not
locked into that vendor.
So if they need to replace
one aspect of that system,
they can hire someone
else that also
complies with that standard
and that part can be replaced.
That lowers costs,
increases competition,
and it means again that they're
not locked into that vendor.
Lee.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] security
at all or [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Usually, the systems
have strong standard encryption.
Part of the standard is
what encryption is used
and what encryption algorithms
are used, hashing, et cetera.
Yeah.
So the Charlie card has
pretty weak encryption,
40 bits I think, and the
same key on every card.
So a long time ago, someone
cracked the key by brute force
and that's the same key
on every Charlie card.
So once that key is public,
anyone with the equipment
could load a fake
balance to the card
because the cards are the ones
having the balance in the AFC
system here and not
the fare engine.
That means that effectively,
you can lie to the fare system
and say that you have
more money than you have.
Much harder to do with
any modern system,
certainly contact
with a bank card
which has a very strong
encryption and unique keys
per card.
AUDIENCE: Did MIT students
get caught doing that?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
The MIT students
were the first to do this.
They were caught and
there was some issue.
Which I think it ended up
being just a slap on the wrist,
but there was a lot
of issue with it.
Because they wanted
to publish a paper
or publish something and
then that was an issue.
OK.
So integration across agencies
of a region is possible.
That's one of the reasons for
moving towards smart cards,
especially in regions
that have many providers.
But it's challenging, and
usually the challenges
are less technical and more
about trust and business
and who gets to decide
what color the card is
or exactly what the
fare policy will be.
This is another
interesting thing.
In some countries, and
I'm thinking specifically
of Japan and China, there
are examples of retail stores
that have partnered
with a transit agency
and you can use the card
at retail locations.
Hong Kong is an example of that.
There's more than 100 retail
locations that accept Octopus.
And in Japan, I know that
there are entire cities where
there's like a whole mall and
this is what most people use
as a charge card.
So that's interesting.
If you don't have very
tough privacy laws,
as you do in Europe and the US--
I'm not sure what
they are in Japan,
but there was some
research where
they were combining all the
data from shopping and transit
to get really interesting
behavioral analytics.
And you can do
interesting things
like offer discounts at stores
if you do something in transit.
So there's a lot of very
interesting [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Our company
did the same thing
and once [INAUDIBLE].
So after that, we are
very careful about dealing
with [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Yeah.
Thanks for sharing.
So contactless bank cards.
We started talking
about this, we've
mentioned that multiple times.
Here's the logic for it.
A transit agency
would prefer not
having to deal with the
complexities and costs of fare
collection.
Essentially, if you
have a fare system,
it's like having a small bank.
It doesn't give out loans,
it doesn't do other things
that banks do, but
you are dealing
with money and the cards
and customer service related
to cards and all those things.
Banks do that, and
they do it very well.
So why not outsource that
part of the business to banks?
There are multiple banks so
they can get competition.
So credit card companies
specialize in payment;
contactless bank
cards are very secure,
much more so than
say the Charlie card;
you can use cards like
this in several ways.
So you could directly
use them for payment
as you would at
a retail location
or you can use the token that
identifies that card, tying it
to an account.
And then your fare engine can
calculate what the fare will be
and capping and all that.
And then on a
regular basis, there
would be a charge to your
credit card or account
for whatever total
was calculated.
So that also enables
Apple Pay and Android Pay.
If you can put your
credit card on your phone,
then you can use your phone
to get into the system.
In London, people love that.
It reduces fare
collection costs.
So why?
Not necessarily obvious.
So it simplifies
customer communication.
You don't have to issue
new cards to people,
you don't have to explain
how you pay because people
know how to use cards.
It relies on open
standards so there's
more competition on the market.
There's several
banks, for example,
and you could have
banks compete for who
will give you a better deal in
terms of fees on these cards.
It outsources some aspects
of customer service to banks.
So if my card stopped
working, who's
going to get the phone call,
the transit agency or the bank?
And it eliminates costs of sort
of creating and distributing
smart cards.
So there's several ways in
which this is reducing costs.
London has successfully
been able to reduce
the number of station attendants
and especially of booths
where they sell Oyster cards and
have customer service related
to Oyster cards.
They've been able to close
those and save money.
And then there's
an equity issue,
and this is what is
always sort of brought up
when you talk about
contactless bank cards, which
is what about the unbanked?
The poorest people are the ones
who don't have a bank account.
So what can you do about that?
Does that make this not work?
So there are multiple
ways of addressing that.
An agency can issue cards
that have preloaded balance.
So that person could interact
with the agency, not the bank.
They don't necessarily
need a bank account.
You can have banks
offer free accounts.
So you can try to
encourage people
to open accounts that have
no fee, no minimum balance.
So some [INAUDIBLE] special
accounts created for that.
And one other issue
is that you must
be able to obtain these
cards at many locations.
If you move towards
a system like this
and you can only get one
of these sort of equity
issued cards if you want from
one station downtown, that
means that the person who
depends on two or three buses
to get into downtown
can't easily get a card.
So you must be able
to maybe get these
at several retail
locations or have
fare vending machines
in multiple places,
especially in zones of high
concentrations of people
that depend on transit and
don't have bank accounts.
OK.
So there are ways of
dealing with that.
Boston is considering now
what they call AFC 2.0.
They're sort of
branding it that way.
And they're probably
going to be moving forward
with the London model of
using contactless bank cards.
So we'll see how it
plays out and we'll
see what that does to the
payment industry in general
in the US in terms of that means
more people will have these.
Does that mean that a lot of
readers at retail locations
will start accepting that,
and what will that do?
It's a question.
We'll see what happens.
OK.
Last topic is fare analytics.
So obviously, lots of data is
generated by these systems.
We've used it for
all the [INAUDIBLE],,
you've looked at it
in your homework.
So here's an example from one of
the students in the transit lab
who has one more
year to graduate,
but he's done great work.
His name is Andrew Stutz.
And one of the
examples of his work
is dashboard, where you can
look at all sorts of fare
transactions by fare product, by
pass or no pass, by user type.
And you can sort of filter
and see exactly who's
using your system how often.
Let me see if I can
show that to you live.
OK.
So here's AFC validations
for October 2015.
So if I want to
see, for example,
here we're looking
at everything.
So we're looking at tickets and
cards and passes and monthly
passes and pay-as-you-go.
So if I want to look at
stored value, so no passes,
I'll sort of filter that out.
Then of course tariff type
becomes 100% pay-as-you-go.
And then you see the breakdown
between cards and tickets
for stored value use.
We see the trends by time
of day here and by date.
So you can see that weekends
are lower and the user type
right here.
So adults very high and then
senior students below that.
If you want to look at
passes, for example,
we could then say passes and
monthly passes in particular.
You see that most of those
are cards, not tickets.
Makes sense.
Higher number of students
than we saw before, et cetera.
So you can really
sort of play with this
and understand how the
market segments itself
with these different
fare products
that people are purchasing
based on the fare policy.
And there's another
dashboard for fare revenue.
So these are fare revenues
by month across many years.
And you can see
the total up here.
But you can break it down again.
So you can look at how much
of it is monthly passes
and you can see how much
of it is normal commuter
pass versus commuter rail.
And you can see, if you're
interested in students,
here's your students.
So you can really slice and
dice it any way you want to.
And there's many
more applications,
but I just wanted to
demonstrate a few.
OK.
So that was it.
I'm not going to lecture
anyone for this semester.
So I'll still come.
And I'll let you
know about the test
as soon as I have more
information on it.
Any questions on fare
policy, fare structure,
fare technology?
No.
All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]